you can kind of see in the body language
and stuff you're like raw you're trying
to turn old like what's going on but
it's similar what do you mean because um
there aren't many men in the church
there aren't there are many men in the
truck no I think it's like 70 women yeah
yeah now because the men don't get
behind this they're like I came to
church for a pure wife why are these
hoes in the church
it's true and then now they're gonna
make me wait when the last guy I got it
for the last ten guys got it for free
yep I don't get with this [ __ ] I think I
think that is such a
backward strategy by a woman right this
is why there's so many like single women
in the church like it's it's just the
strategy you're you're you're balling
backwards like really and truly you're
balling backwards because it's like if
you think that going to church is gonna
get you the man that you want when the
church is mostly women and most of the
men in church are already taken we like
that's not the place you're better off
doing this you better have gone to the
club well I don't know to the bar or I
don't know to somewhere to find men you
don't go to church a lot of women do
that a lot of women do I think they they
start off going to church thinking oh
yeah I'm gonna go to church and maybe I
might find a good man but when you
really actually delve into the faith I'm
not going to say religion because it
depends on what kind of they did find a
good man but yeah if you yeah I'm saying
like when you when a person goes to
church and they delve into the faith it
becomes it moves away from looking for a
man you're not you're no longer looking
for a man you're looking for your
relation ship with God once you gain
that relationship with God first
whatever you don't get a man no no no
you actually you do you do because you
then I feel like most of the things that
you speak about they are within Women of
Faith No no I think there's some
situation is Savage because I'm not
gonna lie it depends on what type of
church you go to that's what I'm saying
no at the moment no okay but but it
literally depends on which ones you go
to because some are there are women that
will go to find their husband and the
husband might already be taken so then
it now becomes a family affair inside
yeah and it is common in certain
the issue with churches is that one it
tells girls that you need to find a guy
that's an equally yoked as you yes and
there aren't no I've been in a lot of
different churches they all say the same
thing you need to find a guy that's
equally yoked what happens there aren't
enough guys in the church there's one
guy usually for every three girls so so
there you can't find the guy that's
equally old right on top of that they
they also want you to donate it's like
that ties or whatever 10 of your income
now how what now most women are on track
to be homeless when they're 65 they're
one cancer diagnosis away from being on
the streets because they don't have the
2.5 million to retire they need to
retire now I know here you guys have
saved without the NHS yeah yeah but at
some point that stuff's gonna run out
they can't do it forever
we've been going for a very long time
yeah it's there's going to be there's
going to be Pro they're predicting that
in a lot of major cities there's going
to be a lot of issues because like a lot
of the social safety nets that are
unsustainable even in England which is
true and but it we're used to it well
accustomed to it we will find a way
though I didn't they won't figure away
with the government it's about going
back to work but that's what women do
they always assume somebody else is
going to take care of their poor
decisions but going back to the church
though Paul right like I said my own
anecdote story that yeah you've heard
yeah and that whole equally yoked thing
like women when when it comes to 70 of
the church being female and
there are all the men in it basically
all the men in the church are taken the
women are going to have to go outside of
the church to find a man and then when
they find a man outside of the church
the pastor says oh he's not equally
yoked get rid of him so the church is
perpetually keeping women single it
depends on the church and this is my
point it's not going to church is not to
come and find a man going to church is
to strengthen your relationship with God
who is a man yes he's a man he's
whatever you want you are going to find
Amanda you will find a man but my point
is if you go to church without the
intentions of I'm going here
specifically to look for a man you will
end up finding the correct man if you
strengthen your relationship with God if
you understand your faith more you will
end up going out and you will meet a man
he may not be equally yoked at the time
but you're like you know you were saying
about like a woman that's supportive a
woman that's encouraging XYZ if you're
looking for a man of Faith you will find
a man that may want that faith and and
he will eventually become just as
faithful as you are church is not to
foreign
if what you're saying was true then
there would be results to show for it
but they're in every church I go to even
even in England it is three women for
every one man there is a surplus of
single childless women and so like what
you're saying isn't correct because if
it was correct there would be results to
show it yeah I don't know I go to a
church and every every month there's at
least two people being married
okay so how many are in the congregation
they're in the congregation what
percentage of women would you say is in
your church
it's probably the same percentage you're
saying like 70 percent there like at
that church some of them some of them
met at the church some of them met
outside the church and came to the
church some of them yeah some of them
met at the church or some of them were
introduced through the church if that
makes sense but I'm saying that's that's
exception not the rule so that that
happens I'm starting to realize yeah
you've been on this podcast I'm clearly
um no but it's not because you said even
in your church it's three women to every
one guys that means at least two are
single that means the majority of women
even in your church are single yes but
the point is the rate of marriage is
quite high in the church people are in
serious relationships but that's not
that's not good why if two out of the
three girls are single I don't know the
the full percentage but what I see is
that when you're going to church and at
some point all of those men are going to
be married yeah off and they're still
going to be 70 of women other men come
into the church but my whole point is
church is not to go and look for man so
if you take that out of the equation you
may find the correct man I I understand
so if you take a church out of the
equation you may find the correct man no
I'm saying if you take look go into
church to look for a man out of the
equation you will find the correct man
church is about your faith in
manifestation I I under I understand I
understand what you're saying that you
shouldn't go to church to um to look for
a man
but with with what Pearl is saying there
comes a point in women's life they
realize
I I need a certain type of man because
I'm going to get to a point where my
eggs ain't aching no more and I'm
getting old and I know that a good man
is in church so let me go find God in a
church and yes you shouldn't I don't
think you should do that because it's
like you're going there with the wrong
intentions but that is the mindset of
some women is that they do go there to
find somebody so that they don't end up
alone when you go there as your self
who's now found good what obligation
does that man in church who may be a
good man have towards you and your
Madness there's no like you're coming to
him
with all of this baggage like oh I found
God now but really and truly you don't
understand how men think men aren't
thinking oh she's found God now men are
looking at your bag it's saying
do I really want to get involved with
that like it doesn't matter church or
not it could be mosque I don't care
Church mosque synagogue it doesn't
matter where you go that's that's the I
mean you know God might heal but but the
men don't forget yeah and that's the lie
that's the lie that that like oh my gosh
I have a whole bit on how church markets
being a hoe I swear to God I said that
yeah I swear because this is what they
do they tell girls you can do whatever
in your 20s you can get ran through and
then all you got to do is apologize mean
it and then there's a husband waiting
for you at the end and then and then on
top of that then then they give those
girls a platform to go talk to younger
girls and say hey I was so broken
I was so broken and then I and then I
found God later and now look at me and
I'm so happy I waited the second time
around and I got married so this is
amazing strategy that only benefits
women and doesn't benefit man because
what does the second guy get he gets a
ran through wife who maybe had one or
two baby daddies that now now he has to
wait for it like then this is what
happens is the church leaves women
single because they they tell girls to
do this that's a terrible plan the
church keeps women perpetually single
like I don't think people understand
like the church is not a place for you
to go and find a man it will I said if
it's not the pastor keeping you single
then it's the actual actions of the
people within the church keeping you
single because the Judgment that happens
a lot of the time in church when a woman
gets with a guy who's not in church
right and they start saying oh is he in
the church no he's not oh so he's he's
of the world or he has or or you have to
bring him to the church yeah what the
like and what what leader guy that's a
leader that is Alpha that has the traits
of a leader is going to want to follow
his woman to church especially with the
way churches are today because even
these mating strategies they only
benefit women
all the women you're not going to church
for each other you're going to church
for God if you invite God into your
relationship it will help to heal your
relationship and that's what like this
whole thing of like forgetting about a
past year you cannot forget about a past
but it depends on your behavior moving
forward and if your behavior let's let's
exclude Sierra because we're not talking
about Sierra here but if you if your
behavior moving forward is of a faith in
God manner then God rules in your
relationship and you become whole yeah
okay do you know that sounds like as a
man yeah God rules in whose relationship
it's my relationship then if you've got
that mindset you'll have a problem in
your relationship no but that's but
that's the point you like women a lot of
women don't understand how men view God
and how women view God because the
reason why women gravitate towards God
is because he's a powerful man
whether it be conscious or subconscious
you put you gravitate towards God
because it's actually a powerful man and
women are attracted to powerful male
figures a man is not sexually attracted
to a powerful male figure it's just not
like he doesn't see him like that no but
I'm right but what I'm trying to say is
the attraction for men for women to be
attracted to powerful men is different
than the attraction of a man being
attracted to a powerful man when you are
constantly talking about God
and your relationship with God have you
have you not heard women say I don't
need a man I've got Jesus Jesus is my
boyfriend Jesus have you not heard women
say that